-Chance and I about to face of
in a game called "Box of Lies.
Here's how it works.
Upstage are nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick a box
take out the object,
describe it to your opponent
They have to guess if you're
lying or telling the truth
We'll play three rounds.
Chance, why don't you
pick the first box?
-All right.
-Audience, what do you think
[ Audience
shouting suggestions ]
-I'm hearing a lot of fives.
-All right.
You're hearing a lot of five
[ Audience
shouting suggestions ]
-You guys are very excited
Have you guys seen
what's inside the boxes?
-No. They just like
the number three.
That's what I'm hearing.
-Okay. That makes sense.
-Yeah.
-[Laughing] What?
-So you can take it out an
put it on the side over here
so the audience can see it
And then you have to
either describe it --
I can't see it at all.
I can just see your --
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
I don't know. I have no idea
-Um, okay, it is a --
Sheesh. I don't know
how to describe this.
It is a live --
[ Laughs ]
I don't even know how to -
All right. This is a live show
-A live show?
-It's a live show.
-Uh-huh.
-With, like,
a talk-show host and a rappe
playing a game
that's very much like this
[ Laughs ]
But with one of
their heads missing.
-So it's a figurine set?
Like a Lego set?
-It's a live show.
-Yeah, I understand.
-I mean, this is a live show
with a talk-show host
and a rapper.
But both of us have heads.
-And both of us have heads
This one does not have heads
-I'm going to say you lie!
[ Drumroll ]
-I'm telling the truth!
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
What? That's so meta!
That is so meta, dude!
We have boxes for heads.
-It's us.
-That's unbelievable.
That is us.
Gosh. You can keep that
if you want to.
-Yeah, so...
-All right. I lost that one.
Guys, want to give me a number
[ Audience
shouting suggestions ]
How come he was three
and I'm two?
Why -- That makes no sense
Here we go. Two.
[ Grunting ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Ohh! Ohh! Ugh!
Hoo!
♪♪♪♪
-[ Laughing ]
-It's not that, uh, bizarre.
Or I could be lying.
-[ Laughs ]
-I could be telling the truth.
That's the fun of the game
[ Laughing wildly ]
[ Laughter ]
Um...
It's a taco shell.
Filled with Papa Smurfs.
[ Laughs ]
It's the only way
I can describe this.
It's a Papa Smurf taco.
[ Laughter ]
-Your eyes aren't lying, though.
I'm going to say it's the truth.
[ Drumroll ]
-I lied!
-Ohh!
-Ooh, that was
good acting, right?
-That was great.
-That was good acting.
All right. Let's do one more
Chance, you are up.
It's a tie game.
[ Audience
shouting suggestions ]
They love you for three.
-All right.
-Okay. All right. Looks like
a light box. Just saying.
-I'm just really, really strong.
This is --
♪♪♪♪
[ Harmonizing ]
[ Chomping ]
-Sorry. I'm just doing
an antelope grazing.
-It's funny that you said
"antelope grazing."
-Oh.
Because this rhymes with that?
-Because it's actually...
a...
[ Laughter ]
-You can't lie to me, can you?
-No, this a --
-Come on.
It's Uncle Jimmy, dude.
-Committed to memory.
I'm looking at it right now.
-It's Uncle Jimmy.
You can't lie to Uncle Jimmy
-It's a --
It's a pickle
that can't come out of a box
-There you go. Thank you.
Thank you for finally
telling me the truth
because that would be the thin
that you're not doing.
[ Laughter ]
-♪♪ Oh, pickle in a box ♪♪
♪♪ Pickle in a box ♪♪
-♪♪ Oh, naw, naw, naw ♪♪
-♪♪ Pickle in a box ♪♪
-And finally, I say,
you lie, my friend.
[ Drumroll ]
-Oh, my God.
You might be right.
-He did not lie!
He's the one and only
Chance the Rapper!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The winner, Chance the Rapper!